it's started about seven years ago and I
found myself in a very funny position
that perhaps some people can relate to
is that I was working I had a
comfortable life but I felt kind of dead
inside
just creatively disconnected and very
disturbed and at that and felt quite
ungrateful for that and September 11th
happened and the more I began to read
the more I began to realize how ignorant
I was to the rest of the world and sort
of frightened at the level of my own
ignorance and perhaps how it contributed
to you know in a teeny way the direction
in which the world is going in and it
was sort of one of those light bulb
moments where I was just like I have to
change my life and I'm really not using
my skillset properly and so I did a lot
of research for about a year came up
with the idea for the book put together
this kind of mock book where I felt like
first of all what I saw especially after
9/11 now actually is when you read the
news especially the front page you see
explosions and rubble and bodies but
very rarely do you know about the life
in between so the goal was was to have
displaced persons speak for themselves
and write for themselves and document
their life and have graphic novels woven
through loud
it's basically about voiceless persons
all over the world people who've lived
in extremities and basically the books
goal was to find these hidden sort of
elusive stories that popular media
doesn't cover like underage women and
brothels speaking for themselves how
they feel about their lower half child
recently escaped child soldiers from
Burma you know the family of a woman who
was in Juarez who was found murdered in
a field a cotton field a children's
story about hiv/aids in Malawi and it
was basically to bring forward these the
issues that are actually I believe our
issues and affect all of us eventually
into a popular form like a much more
mainstream format I mean first of all I
think that on a personal level you know
after so so many years of working on
this book I realized that my ignorance
is a form of act active abandonment of
these issues and I think that I I do
feel now our responsibility to not be
ignorant and to educate myself I and I
think that these stories actually like a
locally I hope that people read this
book and realize that in many ways this
book is a metaphor for what exists in
our own communities
and I think you know art is is elevates
our humanity I really believe that and
I'd like to think that people can be
inspired by what they see in this book
and perhaps seek these stories out in
their own community obviously the book
needs to get out there as a way of
talking about what's going on in Burma
in Chechnya in Malawi and Juarez in in
each country and each it's it's really
outrageous what's going on and I'm
hoping for a grassroots movement to
begin to begin to move these
and finally take some action to get to
stop these things